[Musique]
59 croix 59 victimes toutes mortes de la
lettre
des jeunes des moins jeunes des russes
des islandais des anglais mais surtout
des acadiens repose à jamais ici au bord
de l'eau ici on est des cimetières des
lépreux dac située à tracadie c'était
ici que tu es premier lazaret à tracadie
1849 à 10 896 la maladie en a fait des
marginalisés
la plupart quand on est même le village
en camion tienne moi peur de à propager
la bactérie ailleurs qui en disait
fermement intimité apport qui était
consacrée vraiment aux lépreux les
origines de la lèpre au nouveau
brunswick sont nébuleuses ce qu'on en
sait on peut le découvrir au musée de
tracadie grâce à une exposition
entièrement dédié à ce pan peu connue de
l'histoire que c'est nos droits dans
cette région ici de 2 to canada qu'il ya
eu donner plus de choix nié y avait un
hôpital prenez plus lorsque la maladie
éclate au 19e siècle les autorités isole
rapidement les personnes déclarées
positives elles sont envoyés par bateau
puis séquestrés sur cette petite île
près de miramichi
les premiers malades ils sont arrivés en
juillet 1844 sur l'e17 elle devait être
soigné puis à voir un médecin
il y avait un médecin de miramichi qui
devait les visiter et aller de temps en
temps les voir mais il les voyait pas il
y avait tellement peur des restos vont
veiller rester au bord de l'eau rien
sorti toutes les rapports médicales de
l'époque l'eau mais c'était très star
c'est triste à lire sur les chars drake
les conditions sont pitoyables plusieurs
lépreux tente de s'enfuir d'autres
mourront sur l'île une quinzaine
survivront cinq ans plus tard en 1849
les malades sont ramenés à tracadie dans
un établissement pour traiter la lèpre
le seul centre du genre au canada
des religieuses venues de montréal
veille sur eux dans un lazaret comme
celui ci il faut conserver leur espoir
de guérir mais l'arrivée des lépreux sur
la terre ferme terrorisent la population
raconte soeur d'aig tout le monde
évitera dorénavant le village par
crainte de la maladie
la réputation de tracadie en prendra un
coup des gens ont dit on à tout nouveau
brunswick on a détourné tracadie si on
ne fallait pas pas aussi dans tracadie
le poisson les bleuets s'était moqué
miramichi sur nos consoles parce que ce
serait comme ont dû saler pour ce marché
l'histoire veut que 327 l'épreuve est
été soigné au nouveau brunswick
jamais les religieuses non contracté la
maladie en près d'un siècle à les
soigner
la dernière victime est morte en 1964 le
lazaret ensuite fermé ses portes
l'histoire des lépreux dans ce coin de
pays et méconnue au point que c'est en
travaillant au musée que la jeune guide
interprète a appris que sa famille avait
été touché par la lettre c'est une
histoire unique qui a pas ailleurs on
est à moins d'un énième au canada
donc c'est sûr ça se sait l'intérêt pour
ces projets l'histoire des acadiens
c'est l'histoire de la maladie qui a
atteint les copains qui a touché les
acadiens de la région nous
cet été les curieux pourront découvrir
cette terre où les lépreux ont été
enterrés parce que le musée s'assure de
garder bien en vie cette histoire qu'on
a trop longtemps voulu cacher ici
geneviève normes à radio canada tracadie